hello and welcome to swipe coming up
ever thought about renting out your dog
we take a look at the web sharing
economy social media & Saatchi our
activists are heading online to send a
message to Russia during the winter
olympics storytelling sensations the
e-book technology promising to help
readers really feel the words and with
side-scrolling skateboarders and
suburban sea life all in this week's
games of you from renting out spare
rooms to borrowing bikes and online
economic revolution is now underway an
increasing number of startups are coming
onto the market based around the web
sharing economy it's a concept that's
challenging the old notions of what we
really need to own and how much we
consume skies Katy Spencer has been
finding out more borrowing a stranger's
dog might not immediately seem like the
answer to the excesses of consumer
capitalism but this is part of a growing
online movement a shift towards
collaborative consumption the sharing
economy stems from matching what someone
has with what someone needs in the case
of borrow my doggy calm that means man's
best friend I heard about the website
through some friends you get the best of
both worlds I get a part-time dog the
owners get a break and the dog gets lots
of love and attention they get out for
probably longer than if we were just
paying for a dog walker and yeah they
seem extremely extremely happy of course
peer-to-peer lending like this requires
an element of trust but with like minded
people seeking out the service it's a
concept that appears to be working we
have thousands of member signing up
every single week not only do the
brackets expect some happy dog time and
the owner gets some some time off
knowing that dog is well taken care of
but at the same time people also get to
know each other really well locally so
people actually making friends in recent
years hundreds of sharing startups have
come onto the market websites that let
you rent or lend just about anything
from the empty parking space outside of
your house
to last night's leftovers this place is
in mine but I'm staying here for the
weekend Airbnb which lets people rent
out their rooms to cash-strapped
travelers has taken the concept to
another level last year it says it
generated 502 million pounds in economic
activity in the UK but it's faced some
problems with old regulations we have
pretty clear laws today for private
people and also for businesses but not
for you know private people running a
business out of their home so we are
working very proactively with regulators
all over the world and clarifying these
laws and figuring out how we can work
together sharing isn't always easy the
company has been in the firing line in
New York and San Francisco accused of
flouting state regulations over
short-term let's larger hotels even
medium-sized hotels are saying it's an
unfair playing field we're having to pay
these taxes and regulations and they're
not peer-to-peer businesses are a
powerful force in the market providing
millions of people with an extra source
of income but it's not all about making
money sites offering people the chance
to give away their goods have also taken
off frustrated with kitty consumerism
blogger Hattie garlic built a massive
following writing about her experiences
of trying to raise her son for a whole
year without spending a penny the
project sounds like it harks back to
some kind of nostalgic era of childhoods
but in fact it was all about the
internet it wouldn't have been possible
at all without the web collaborative
consumption is proving a force to be
reckoned with challenging traditional
ideas of what we really need to own and
raising questions about whether we've
more to gain through sharing Keita
Spencer sky Hughes you're watching swype
coming up the ebooks that lets you feel
what you read but first after four years
of waiting the Winter Olympics is back
but not for the first time the sports in
danger of being overshadowed by politics
last year Russia passed a law
restricting the freedoms of gay people
that have also been some disturbing
cases of homophobic attacks no
campaigners are using social media to
put pressure on Russia to do something
about it skies Tom Platt reports dear
gbt brothers and sisters in Russia dear
brothers and sisters in Russia to russia
with love messages from around the world
telling LGBT russians that it gets
better love and strength for you all
from the It Gets Better Project in
Switzerland according to recent research
almost three-quarters of Russians don't
think homosexuality should be accepted
by society in the face of this
increasing intolerance human rights
groups are using social media to show
gay Russians they're not alone if you
normally would you say that see for me
organizations like all out on the human
rights campaign are using hashtags love
always wins and love conquers hate to
spread their messages seizing the
spotlight of the Sochi games their
campaigns capitalize on share-worthy
content now all it has 1.9 million
members and growing all the time and
actually how we see that we were going
to change the world we're going to
mobilize millions of people and their
social networks to build the world where
everyone can your love freely and love
how they choose hashtag love always wins
that encouraged people to share that
video around and then when people see
that video here that these laws are
happening you're the more people are
going to join our movement and help make
change happen and the power of social
media can be great 150 million tweets
were sent during the London Olympics but
even if a gay rights organization can
harness that power will it make a
difference even if we don't see Putin
move on this even if we don't see the
major corporations that are endorsing
the Olympics change their stance I think
this will communicate to the people in
Russia who are in the LGBT community
that they really matter but as
international organizations gain
momentum domestic campaigns are
faltering the founder of children 404
and LGBT online community in Russia
faces charges of sharing homosexual
propaganda she could face a fine of
around 2,000 pounds there's a feeling in
the country that social media
campaigning also needs to succeed at
home other campaigns from other
countries but an intention to a
situation in Russia is great but it's
better when they
can make campaigns instead of fresh show
the Olympic Games puts the international
focus and international campaigning on
Russia whether this activism comes from
inside the country or not LGBT russians
just hope it will be a victory for gay
rights Tom Platt Sky News you're
watching swype coming up changing your
look in an instant more on Intel's magic
mirror but first we've all read a book
where we really feel connected to the
characters and just in time for a
national storytelling week scientists at
MIT have developed a way to actually
plug you into the pages next ileana has
been finding out whether we'll be
strapping ourselves in rather than
curling up with a latest bestseller it
looks like something from a
science-fiction novel not the new way to
read one but this is a prototype of
sensory fiction a wearable book project
from the Massachusetts Institute of
Technology the oversized pages have 150
programmable LEDs that can change color
to match the mood of your chapter but
it's this vest that make sure the story
sets your heart racing quite literally
it's not just your imagination that will
take cues from the words on the page
sensors airbags and vibration motors
will tighten loosen and even heat you up
the actions getting steamy but before
you start looking for a wearable version
of Fifty Shades that's not quite what
the creator's had in mind fantastic
stories would be great for that but also
maybe like kids books may be really
interesting and they release them what
not really simple stories but they're a
bit more simple so instead of scouring
the shelves we could just be suiting
ourselves up to the spines but not
everyone's convinced that book shops
need to start investing in clothes
hangers and there are awful lot of books
that have moved me some of them to tears
and I think that book isn't doing its
job if it requires the supplement of
technology to squeeze you or make you
feel pain it might end up being more
important than ever what type of novel
you
picked up a caricature of burning
melting obsessed with true love before
long you could be popping into places
like this to really make sure the book
you're reading does have a happy ending
Nick's taliani Sky News you're watching
swype coming up we'll be putting our
skating skills to the test in this
week's games review but first here's a
roundup of anything you might have
missed over the last few days Facebook
turned 10 this week and to mark the
occasion every user was treated to their
own personalized video set to slightly
dodgy music we would give them the
chance to reflect back on some of the
more questionable posts we've put up
over the years Mark Zuckerberg said he
hoped the next 10 will be even better
but with some researchers claiming young
people are moving on to cooler new sites
nowadays shoot Facebook be worried
facebook right now is facing a huge
amount of competition and a real
challenge to stay relevant with certain
demographics for certain purposes so for
example kids are gravitating to things
like Tumblr and Instagram and snapchat
and whisper Sony is getting rid of its
troubled PC business the Japanese
electronics company revealed it expects
to make a full-year loss of around 665
million pounds battered by stiff
competition from Samsung and Apple sony
has acknowledged it won't be able to
stop losing money in its vaio pc or
bravia tv operations despite repeated
promises to do so one of the biggest
names in tech has a new boss microsoft
is a known satya nadella as chief
executive to replace Steve Ballmer he's
a Microsoft veteran of 22 years and is
currently in charge of the cloud
computing side of the business and
finally good news for anyone who's ever
been dragged to the shops and had to set
outside the changing rooms waiting for
their other half of course mine would
never do such a thing trying on clothes
could be set to get a whole lot easier
intel has been showing off its digital
memory mirror the idea is to allow
shoppers to virtually try on multiple
outfits as well as recording those you
have tried on so you can compare your
looks so is it a glimpse of
future or just a gimmick if someone is
constantly trying on an item but never
actually purchases that item afterwards
the retailer will be able to send you
offers and say are you sure you don't
want to buy this would you take it if it
was temps and a four or different deals
and actually start to have a
conversation with the consumer that they
wouldn't be having before unless a
transaction was made dad's with
tentacles side-scrolling skateboarders
and a little bit of lara croft it's fair
to say we've got a mixed bag in this
week's games of you cares a mcdonald's
been taking us through our peck of the
best if you remember the Tony Hawk's Pro
Skater games from the 90s and early
2000s then Ollie Ollie will take a
nostalgic box for you it's a 2-d game
where you're on a skateboard it starts
off being really hard but once you get
the hang of it once you get your fingers
around the controls it's really really
fun that's all about sketching together
endless combos so grinding and tricks in
the air and all about giving a thumbs of
work out as well it's really fun it's a
high score game so it's very addictive
as well it's the best skateboarding game
that's been around in a very very long
time octodad is a game where you have to
make sure that nobody realizes you're an
octopus which may be the best previs for
a game i've ever heard of essentially
you have all of your eight Wibbly limbs
tucked into a suit and you have to try
and take care of your wife and family
without being able to do really basic
tasks like pouring coffee or mowing
along without sending everything
flinging everywhere the fun from octodad
comes from the control system it's
really hard to control your tentacles at
once but instead of being frustrating
it's just really really funny you only
have to look out to that for about 30
seconds to realize how fun it's going to
mean to play
you
so octodad is being pursued by a crazy
sushi chef who is determined to make his
true nature apparent to the world so
half the game is about performing basic
task for your family and you know trying
to pretend not to be onto us and the
other half of the game is trying to
escape here crazy sushi chef who wants
to turn you into sushi Tomb Raider first
came out last year around this time this
time it's out again but it's on
PlayStation 4 and Xbox one has anyone
listening please respond it does look an
awful lot better on PlayStation 4 runs
at 60 frames per second which isn't an
Xbox one if you've already played tomb
raider on ps3 or xbox 360 then you might
not want to spend the money to play it
again but if you haven't played it this
is definitely the addition to go for
it's a great game it's a really
fantastic rebirth for lara croft i like
it just as much this year let it last
year broken age is a beautiful adventure
game that harks back to the old days of
point-and-click and the great thing
about it is that is not actually too
difficult to play so no matter who you
are what you like you can play broken
age it's a beautiful whimsical surreal
tale you play half of it as a young man
and half of its young woman and at the
end their tails are kind of interwoven
it's it's the most beautifully strange
game I've played this year so far it's
got an art style that's kind of paper
crafting kind of watercolor e very
beautiful to look at it's got very
strange puzzles that are you know tricky
enough to work out without being so
tricky that they make you annoyed it's
just a really really great for hours
it's like a beautiful story book that
you might read well that's a lot for
this week remember you can catch up with
the breaking tech stories or week on Sky
News for an iPad or smartphone apps and
sky news com we'll see you next time
you